[Música]
cerca de 100 documentos clasificados de
Estados Unidos se filtraron en redes
sociales como Twitter y Telegram parte
de la información son secretos de
seguridad Nacional sobre la guerra en
Ucrania incluyendo la capacidad de
defensa aérea de este país
el juez más antiguo de la Corte Suprema
de Estados Unidos
aceptó viajes de lujo financiados por un
multimillonario donante del partido
republicano Thomas se defiende diciendo
que no tenía por qué reportarlos y que
eran un regalo de un amigo cercano
aumenta la tensión en medio oriente en
Israel hubo dos ataques en un solo día
primero un tiroteo dejó dos muertos y
luego un vehículo embistió a varios
turistas entre la vida Esto ocurre horas
después de que Israel bombardeara el sur
del Líbano y la franja de gaza
Bienvenidos a las noticias
internacionales aquí en France 24 yo soy
María Clara calle y es un placer
acompañarlos iniciamos en Estados Unidos
este viernes se filtraron en redes
sociales cerca de 100 documentos
clasificados con secretos militares de
ese país que van desde la estrategia de
Washington en China y el lindo Pacífico
hasta medio oriente también hay
información sobre la guerra en Ucrania
el pentágono está investigando Cómo se
hicieron públicos parte de la
información parece haber sido alterada
lo que ha llevado aquí eff a culpar a
Moscú veamos
según un informe de The New York Times
se han publicado documentos clasificados
sobre la guerra en Ucrania en varias
redes sociales esos documentos detallan
los planes secretos estadounidenses y de
la otan para la asistencia militar a
Ucrania el pentágono ha abierto una
investigación sobre la filtración pero
por ahora hay más preguntas que
respuestas
lo misterioso de estos documentos es que
parecen Auténticos pero al mismo tiempo
algunas partes han sido manipuladas por
lo que no sabemos realmente cómo se
filtraron desde Qué institución de qué
lado se filtraron
el medio informa de que los documentos
clasificados aparecieron por primera vez
en el sitio web de imágenes for Chen y
antes de eso en un grupo de discusión de
videojuegos en Minecraft discord server
antes de ser ampliamente compartidos en
Telegram un investigador del medio
bellinghat ha estado rastreando la
cronología de las filtraciones los
primeros El documento se compartieron
los días 1 y 2 de marzo antes de volver
a publicarse el 5 de abril en 4chan y en
canales de Telegram
funcionarios ucranianos han culpado
directamente a Moscú afirmando que los
documentos contenían una gran cantidad
de información ficticia y presentaban
las características de una operación de
desinformación rusa con el objetivo de
sembrar la discordia entre Ucrania y sus
aliados
Rusia Está tratando de influir en la
sociedad ucraniana con información y
sembrar el miedo el pánico la
desconfianza y la duda es un
comportamiento muy típico de Rusia Son
elementos estándar de los juegos
operativos de la inteligencia rusa y
nada más Mientras tanto funcionarios
estadounidenses han estado trabajando
para que se borren los mensajes de las
redes sociales ante la preocupación de
que una filtración de inteligencia de
este nivel pueda perjudicar el futuro
intercambio de inteligencia entre
Estados Unidos y Ucrania seguimos en
Estados Unidos porque el juez más
antiguo de la Corte Suprema de justicia
de ese país se defendió este viernes
ante la polémica que protagoniza el
medio investigativo Pro pública reveló
que el conservador Clarence Thomas
recibió durante dos décadas viajes de
lujo que pagaba harland un millonario
donante del partido republicano Thomas
replicó que no está obligado a
reportarlos y los catalogó como una
hospitalidad por parte de uno de sus
amigos más queridos Marta Moya tiene la
historia
la polémica llega a la Corte Suprema de
Estados Unidos el medio sin fines de
lucro Pro pública divulgó el jueves un
extenso reportaje en el que se refleja
que Clarence Thomas uno de los
magistrados del más alto tribunal
estadounidense habría aceptado viajes de
lujo por parte del donante millonario
del partido republicano harland desde
república sostienen que la frecuencia de
los regalos al juez no tiene precedentes
conocidos en la historia moderna de la
Corte Suprema los obsequios del Magnate
de Dallas de Thomas incluyen viajes a
bordo de yates y jets privados sin
embargo el magistrado publicó un
comunicado en el que sostiene que hizo
todo acorde a la Norma y el millonario
declaró que con sus regalos nunca trató
de influir en las decisiones judiciales
de su amigo a principios de mi mandato
en la corte busqué la orientación de mis
colegas y otras personas en el poder
judicial y me informaron que este tipo
de hospitalidad personal de parte de
amigos personales cercanos que no tenían
asuntos ante la Corte no tenían que ser
informados siempre he tratado de cumplir
con esas pautas que ahora se están
cambiando ya que el comité de la
conferencia judicial responsable de la
divulgación financiera para todo el
poder judicial Federal anunció el mes
pasado nuevas normas y tengo por
supuesto intención de seguir esta guía
en el futuro desde la Casa Blanca por su
parte evitaron hacer comentarios al
respecto es algo de lo que debe hablar
la Corte Suprema Simplemente no voy a
comenzar sobre esto en este momento cree
que el congreso debe actuar es algo que
el congreso debe discutir solo digo que
no voy a comentar sobre esto en este
momento la nueva Norma que aplica sobre
los miembros del poder judicial desde el
pasado mes obliga a jueces de la Corte
Suprema y de los juzgados federales a
declarar todo tipo de viajes y obsequios
con objeto de mejorar la transparencia
de las instituciones
Estados Unidos pasamos a medio oriente
concretamente a Israel donde hubo dos
ataques este viernes en medio de la
escalada de violencia primero un carro
fue baleado en las discordania ocupada y
dos mujeres israelíes fallecieron luego
un automóvil atropelló a varias personas
ante La Vid un turista italiano perdió
la vida viajeros más quedaron heridos
estos hechos ocurren en la misma semana
en la que la policía israelí atacó La
mezquita de alaxa en dos noches
consecutivas a lo que el Líbano y la
franja de gaza respondieron con misiles
luego del ejército de Israel bombardeó a
ambos lugares Este es el informe
jornada violenta en Israel un vehículo
se volcó tras intentar un
atropellamiento masivo en el Paseo
marítimo de tel aviv un agente de
policía que se encontraba cerca disparó
al conductor del vehículo cuando
presuntamente intentó sacar un arma
se trata del último suceso violento en
un nuevo aumento de tensiones en medio
oriente unas horas antes en el noreste
de las discordania ocupada tuvo lugar
otro ataque mortal dos hermanas murieron
cuando su vehículo fue atacado a tiros
cerca de un puesto de control en hamra
la madre resultó herida
los ataques ocurren en medio de una
escalada de violencia y después de un
intercambio de bombardeos entre Israel y
milicias palestinas desde la franja de
gaza y el sur del Líbano aunque no hay
pruebas de vínculos entre los hechos el
Primer Ministro Benjamín pidió a la
policía y fuerzas armadas reforzar la
frontera para hacer frente a los ataques
solo puedo decir una cosa nuestros
enemigos nos están poniendo a prueba de
nuevo Y una vez más descubrirán Incluso
en esta prueba que permanecemos juntos
Unidos confiados en nuestra rectitud
por su parte grupo islamista jamás
calificó el hecho de Heroico
la heroica operación que ha tenido lugar
hoy en el Valle del Jordán insiste en
que el pueblo palestino y la resistencia
están Unidos para luchar contra este
gobierno de derechas fascista y
extremista
solamente en los primeros tres meses de
este año el conflicto ha cobrado la vida
de 18 personas en ataques por parte de
palestinos o árabe israelíes y de al
menos 92 palestinos
por primera vez desde que es Papa
Francisco no asiste al vía cruces del
viernes Santo una de las fechas más
importantes de la fe católica El
Vaticano advirtió que el pontífice no
asistiría para protegerse de los vientos
fríos de la noche ya que el papa estuvo
hospitalizado hace una semana por
bronquitis viral sin embargo sí presidió
la pasión de Cristo Rafael Pérez tiene
los detalles
Es la primera vez que el Papa Francisco
de 86 años no asiste al vía crucis su
ausencia se debe a la recomendación
médica de no exponerse a las bajas
temperaturas que azotan Roma tras su
hospitalización la semana pasada por una
bronquitis Sin embargo a la ceremonia
que Recuerda la pasión de Jesús
asistieron unos 20.000 fieles según la
santa sede
[Música]
el dolor causado por la invasión rusa
Ucrania repitió este año y dos de las
estaciones fueron dedicadas a
Latinoamérica
la tercera vez que se detuvo la
procesión un centroamericano hizo un
llamado de atención sobre la corrupción
y el desaliento que provocan el
crecimiento del narcotráfico un flagelo
que trae consigo la dependencia la
explotación y la pérdida de hijos
seguidamente una madre suramericana
contó su parecer por el accionar de las
guerrillas la explosión de una bomba le
hizo perder una de sus piernas en el año
2012 al terminar la jornada Francisco
agradeció por la unión de los católicos
Gracias Señor por la luz que has
encendida en nuestras noches y
reconciliando toda división nos ha hecho
a todos hermanos
más temprano el santo padre protagonizó
un servicio vespertino organizado acorde
a su salud
así llegamos al final de las noticias
pero los invitamos a que sigan con
France 24 porque nosotros regresamos en
minutos con más información
[Música]